hello everyone and welcome to some more
rapid action unleashes usually I upload
only one video per day but today I had
some extra time and I um uh already
played the game uh the one that I've
lost I've uploaded it uh but then I
played three games for for practice uh
also rapid games and I won all three so
it made me think that maybe maybe for
some reason it actually is easier to
play without recording yourself or or
live streaming uh but I I don't think it
should be so uh I'm going to do one more
today so today we're going to do two
rapid games to see if it's possible and
I'm going to play the exact same way I
played with the three games that I did
not record just to check this hypothe
hypothesis uh so let's check it out um
the last game I played offline I had a
black piece one a very nice
game and one of the games was very close
but I was able to win it now one of the
other uh things that are possible is
that uh when I'm playing um without
recording or without streaming I'm
playing in incognito mode or here I
think it's called something uh different
um uh without uh uh without knowing who
my opponent is so I don't know if my
opponent is rated 2, 2100 2200
2500 uh I just play a normal chess
against the position and I think that's
the main reason why it's easier to play
when I'm not recording not the fact that
I'm actually recording so here okay our
opponent goes for the D6 Sicilian and we
go for this
um uh standard open stuff where we
either get the ner or the KH or the
whatever he plays so he goes for the
nider and we're going to play H3 um uh
the the atams attack sometimes I play
something else sometimes I don't okay so
he stops um he stops G4 uh and I'm going
to play G3 here I'm going to play G3
Bishop to G2 maybe Castle King side even
uh but we'll
see uh we'll see what he does
okay so also have to play a little bit
faster uh when I'm not recording I did
play a little bit faster although not
due to recording so here probably I
should avoid castling Queens side uh but
maybe maybe also it's not a terrible
idea so uh it uh sometimes is a little
bit dangerous to Castle Queen side
against the Sicilian as you have all all
of these nasty moves coming in attacking
your queen side but uh yeah now okay the
bishop is on G2 so he wants to play
Knight to C for to attack the queen and
the bishop which is very very
strong and we have to figure out a way
out of
this ah all
right he took
uh yeah he took this bishop to G2 move
seriously uh taking advantage of this
missing piece from this diagonal right
away yeah as he
should so yeah the the the point is that
now with with this H5 and this setup
probably the bishop belonged on
G5 uh so yeah that could also be it so
we're going to play Bishop to G5 now I
know it's wasting a Tempo but what are
you going to
do uh you know like I say it's better to
waste the tempo than the game so now we
had to put the queen on C1 which is a
silly square but we are uh holding on uh
so he doesn't have H6 to kick away the
bishop he has to play Bishop D7 or he
might not he might just leave the leave
with the queen and uh he he will not
care about Bishop captures on F6 and
it's probably not even great to
capture uh but who knows all right so
he's playing much faster yeah he's going
to go Bishop D7 sort of
uh sort of unpinning now some Knight
captures on e4 uh business might be
possible although no since I moved my
queen I don't think it is okay we're
going to
Castle yeah
I have to figure out how to get rid of
this uh pressure on the C file probably
something like C3 and then we somehow
move the Knight yeah probably just
captur and Knight D5 yeah that solves
all my problems not all of them some of
them uh yeah do we go for it now I mean
it's as good good a time as
any uh yeah let's go for it
let's go for
it I have to free up my position
somehow so he has to take and then we're
going to then we're going to deal with
this H3
Pawn or he might be even considering G
captures and really play a fighting
game yeah
not not completely unreasonable I would
probably do that I would probably play G
captures depends on what kind of a day
he's
having yeah g captur might actually be
very
nice yeah we're going to play King H2 so
we don't have to worry about a pawn
push uh but yeah something like this
this and then if H4 G4 and then he
sacrifices the bishop for the two pawns
looks looks kind of scary yeah I have to
also be careful
there um yeah but we'll tackle that when
we when we get to
that yeah he's really contemplating uh G
captur but no he goes for Bishop
captures probably to get some sort of
support for the advancement of the G
Pawn
now uh but
yeah now Knight D5 isn't as
impressive
uh or you know could be even more
impressive but we'll
see I have to play
it I have to play it and and I will not
even have time for B3 C4 probably if he
takes he might open up the position so
C3 will have to be played but I'm happy
with C3 yeah if I can get C3 in uh yeah
I'm definitely feeling the pressure here
okay so he will go for the captures
first as he should but this now allows
me what what exactly does it allow
me uh it allows me to kick away this
Knight yeah allows me B3 B3 is very
annoying because if he loses the control
of
B6 that could be an issue so what was
his plan here
what what just Capt I play I play B3 he
captures captur and H4 completely
ignores the Knight I
capture he captures on G3 is he really
such
a such a
player I mean I have to
check I have to check this is very could
be very strong for him but if if he
doesn't have that then Knight to B6 is a
real
issue no he doesn't have that he he just
doesn't care about Knight
B6 like what is
this
huh yeah he he he just wants to give up
the exchange and uh push H4 I I guess
that's the
plan but it's not going to work all that
well when I capture uh here okay is it
still okay so he might be going for the
Knight uh yeah but now this just
blunders the game completely no F3 and
he
resigns F3 and he gives up a full Rook
here
what yeah I think he really went into
too hard on this probably he's going to
play Rook captures on C2 even here just
uh not give up The Rook for for
for zero compensation but then we just
captur The Rook yeah so yeah this is
resigns for
him all right so it seems like uh
recording was not the problem maybe just
uh playing those three games that I've
won prior to this one sort of um gave me
a confidence boost
but yeah and also I'm just completely
disregarding that he has the E6 Square
yeah okay uh bit of uh unnecessary
rambling there by me uh what are you
going to
do what are you going to
do yeah okay it's nice very
nice yeah I completely missed the E6
Square I feel so
silly um
yeah I mean we're still winning but uh
we're going to have to work work for our
meal a bit a bit
more I have to take it yeah I
do yeah very very very funny
stuff how did I miss that Queen to E6
move so sometimes my my brain really
really does weird
stuff like it's okay not to see like a
three move combination or anything but
not seeing that Queen can actually go to
E6 that's a that's a
problem and uh you know with uh having
problems like those while playing I'm
actually very happy with my position so
but uh we don't care about the bishop if
he captures plays H4 we're going to play
G4 H3 check King H2 nothing really
happening there so we can disregard that
and uh yeah we can disregard
that what's the what's the cleanest way
cleanest way is even to play
play yeah I'd play A3 sort of with a
double attack but then
C4 yeah C4 C4 has to be played it's just
a better position so should be winning
uh and castling although yeah now he can
Castle it's fine he will avoid some
trickery I might have on the queen side
but then he no longer has anything on
the H file and without
that
yeah yeah I'm still still I'm also he's
going to go H4 he doesn't
care very
nice
um it's very nice indeed uh so how do
you deal with Queen A3 we'll play Queen
C7 probably yeah but no then you blunder
the
bishop so Queen A3 you're going to
capture here that's the point yeah
okay I I
understand
but still it's nothing really yeah we go
here he plays capture say capture H3
check is nothing because I just put the
King on G2 and block the block the H
file if he captures that's fine but then
I have Rook
H1 um and he doesn't have the dark
Square
so yeah I think this is okay yeah so
probably this will happen Queen A3 yeah
okay I'm getting very long time so I'm
going to play Queen A3 yeah that's the
that's that's the point where I start
getting low on time when I when I'm
recording it would seem yeah he might
even give a check but yeah now it's
useless yeah so if he doesn't want to
blunder he should capture on G2 first
you know or not at this point it's
probably better for me not saying uh not
saying anything as I've uh already said
quite a lot of silly stuff so okay
very
nice very nice
indeed ah okay okay okay okay I got it I
got
it he wants to take here and then bring
the queen into the game yeah that makes
perfect
sense that actually makes perfect
sense
huh yeah now it seems that I've
blundered the
game
yeah we have to play it like
this you have to play it like this no
other way to do it Knight
F5 it's ugly but someone has to do
it we're blocking the queen and we're
preventing Bishop captures due to Knight
captures on D6
check yeah this is okay so he obviously
sacrifices the queen or he thought that
I was just out of moves and playing
silly moves uh whatever the reason we
win the
queen yeah is a check for something no
it's not it's really
not okay and now it's uh resigns time
for him so it was a pretty brutal game
yeah pretty brutal game yeah we still
have to be a little bit careful we don't
want to allow the Bishops uh to have
their way with our King uh but yeah he's
going to go this is this something yeah
Bishop H4 and
this probably
not yeah let's go here first to prevent
Rook
H6 although it's not preventing it that
considerably
um yeah I mean two Bishops and a rook is
unpleasant yeah he will go for that but
uh yeah the the bishop covers this so I
I pretty much played The Rook move for
no good
reason
uh yeah I'm just going to say that he
doesn't have anything
here go
here sort of minimizing the
counterplay not allowing Rook
G6 and uh that's pretty much it yeah now
we go here and he resigns no we don't go
there right away obviously the bishop is
covering
D7 but yeah that was uh pretty crazy
game pretty crazy game all right so he's
going to continue playing because I'm
down to 1 minute and 20 seconds but
that's more than
enough or it should be you know if I'm
recording it might it might actually not
be um so who
knows uh for the moment without seeing
his move okay so he played Bishop G5
with the idea of Bishop E3 check which
is very nice we're going to stop that no
reason to allow
it uh but we don't want to stop it that
way yeah it's actually a it's actually a
fun
move
yeah down to 58 seconds wow he found a
he found a nasty
move yeah he found a nasty move and he
does control this so if he gets this
could be unpleasant so I
should okay so he does have the movement
of the bishop with tempo
let's go here just so we don't uh run
out of
moves okay we're going to go here simply
because it comes with
Tempo 41
seconds we can pick this up if we need
or we can pick this up I don't want to
go of course not doing that for material
I'm just looking for ways to Checkmate
him with the Rook but the Bishops are
covering all of the important squares
yeah let's give a check just
for for the purpose of giving a check
let's capture this one could be very
dangerous now because he has check and
winning my queen but we will be careful
we will take the bishop and uh that's it
one check will not cause us
harm yeah he can give one check but
that's all there
is
yeah okay now I have to play a little
bit faster because uh well
just okay we go here not a
problem here we go
here you really wants to flag us I
respect that I very much respect that
let's go here wants to go for a check
which will buy him a few more seconds
we're going to go here discovers this
and this
Checkmate uh or he will have to take the
pawn I don't Waits
Checkmate yeah all right Mr unique
player time to
resign uh we were lucky this one so yeah
not bad with this uh win if it happens
uh should be four in a row which is very
nice okay so we're going to go here
will have to take here if he wants to
avoid
mate
great great stuff let's go here uh maybe
I have something faster
but yeah to little time on the clock
he's going to give one last check or he
will play this and be really really
persistent yeah I can I can respect
that nice let's go
here there we go 7 seconds but we did it
yeah it was important not to not to grab
stuff for no reason uh but we were able
to do it uh okay I just uh sorry I just
uh realized that maybe you guys weren't
able to see the clock but uh yeah maybe
was it
invisible yeah sorry if it was I will
check after the game but yeah I finished
on 7 seconds and he had like a minute
and 17 seconds uh but yeah let's check
it out okay so with this win we broke
2200 which is nice uh so on to
2300 now let's uh check out what we
what we horribly played okay so G3 yeah
this is the way to play against H5 if
you
want Bishop G2 I played Bishop E3 okay
this is all very nice very drawish stuff
here um if you guys want to see more of
this I can even maybe I can maybe do it
like this okay so now you see more of
the engine
bar uh yeah this is perfectly fine yeah
so it looks looks ugly but you can play
it yeah now Knight D5 he should play
Bishop captures on H3 which he did but
this is like
weird oh no he should play Bishop
captures on D5 like we discussed in the
game yeah and then play E4 like we
discussed so what was the problem here
what was the problem with my idea of
C3 E3 ah
okay okay shattering my position and
then Bishop G5 going after E3 I block
with Knight F4 and then H4 yeah
okay uh so yeah if you can C10 moves
ahead then you you punish Knight D5 uh
Bishop captures on H3 he played I played
B3 now I'm better better better F3 yeah
I completely missed this Queen T E6 move
to the point where I could I might even
be a little bit embarrassed but I don't
get embarrass so it's fine I play this
captures captures uh what was this C4 no
not C4 you should capture here and then
go Rook F2 okay so here at this point
yeah Queen A3 I'm lost H cap I play H
capts and now where was the
loss okay so I the defense that I found
with Knight to F5 was actually winning
for white uh he should have played uh
Bishop back to d8 just to defend the
Knight and then continue pushing yeah
okay Knight captures here he just
blundered the queen yeah after Knight F5
should have played Bishop to E7 and then
I play King captures and G2 and the game
continues with white being better but uh
you know it's still a game here he just
blundered his Queen and decided to play
on time uh did we have any cleaner ways
of doing it
no uh no mates okay so here it was kind
of mate in
five uh that we sort of
found but
yeah okay so not terrible aside for for
for that one move that really gave him
Advantage uh but yeah what are you going
to
do uh so okay continuing the the streak
we broke 2200 and we will uh try to uh
try to do even better next time uh I
don't know would you like to see
something else other than the Adams
attack against the nro if they play the
nro and whatever you would like to see
just comment in the comment section
below I will try to prepare it I've seen
some of you have been writing you want
to see some gambits and uh you know
against against the D4 which is not
really my specialty in my younger days I
did play a lot of benoni and Beno but uh
you know those were those were my
younger days now I'm more of a Nimo or
even the uh yeah I'm pretty much always
play the NSO against D4 if if I'm
allowed uh but yeah comment and if I if
I see something um that that is possible
for me to deliver I will try to do it I
mean I could play any opening but I'm
just going to be terrible at it and then
you guys will think it's a bad opening
but no it's just I'm a bad player that's
that's the point and uh yeah uh it's uh
uh playing this one rapid game per day
okay now today I played this is like my
fifth rapid games the previous video
that I uploaded I lost and now I've won
four in a row uh really really starting
to enjoy rapid even to the point where
I'm enjoying it more than Blitz and
bullet as uh I don't know I I play a
game here and then it annoys you you've
SP you've invested half half of hour of
your life into this game and if you you
know missplay the opening terribly or if
you don't know how to continue a certain
position that you know you've played
correctly in the opening that bers you
and then you actually go online and you
check how to play it and then hopefully
you'll remember it and you'll be able to
use it in in the games to come uh but
yeah uh that's the that's the game hope
you guys enjoyed it and uh yeah see you
tomorrow with some more rapid action at
the 2200 level uh see you
soon